[Music]
so like Teddy Roosevelt's son Theodore
Roosevelt jr. joins the Harvard freshman
football team
his first game the other team targeted
him because he's the president's son and
nose broken like right away put a huge
gash on his face so Teddy Roosevelt
decided that football's fantastic but
maybe a little bit too violent maybe we
could calm it down and you know in his
spare time he was president so he ended
the russo-japanese war and then was like
I'm also gonna fix I'm gonna say
football so anyway
well where's the jump up Teddy Roosevelt
so Teddy Roosevelt called this meeting
with the heads of the college football
powerhouses and he was like look guys
football pretty violent right like love
the sport doing a great job let's not
kill so many people and so the head
coach of Yale Walter Camp who's known as
the father of American football was like
um
don't talk about my sport that way I
made this sport and we're not gonna
change it like football is football
suck it bro and so the president was
like well this guy just told me to suck
it bro so I think the meeting is a
meeting is adjourned I think the meeting
is adjourned and so they didn't come to
any sort of agreement and at the end of
that season the Newsboys were like extra
extra read all about it 18 deaths
serious there are deaths that are like
that it's kind of funny
eighteen deaths and a hundred and
fifty-nine fatalities fatalities
means deaths
18 deaths and 159 super serious injuries
from football happening now exclamation
point end quote
read about it or don't so Teddy invited
everybody back and he's like hey all all
this stuff just happened
Walter camp I see you raising your hand
I don't acknowledge you we have to
change your sport I get that it's your
baby but sometimes your baby sucks if
you give birth to a baby you're like do
whatever the you want it's gonna
punch people and people are gonna die
your baby needs to be raised properly in
a decent home and the decent home is
let's make some new rules so like what
if crazy stop what if we make first down
instead of five yards make it ten and
then he was like what if you took a ball
and you threw it instead of only just
being able to shove into each other to
move down the field
wouldn't that be wild and people were
like wait you want to throw a ball the
cats like balls are invented to be
thrown walter camp was like okay fine
and so um basically after that meeting
there was like a national standard for
what football was
and it was great and it was all great
because of Teddy Roosevelt and like
nobody knows that they just think Teddy
Roosevelt Oh president or actually
nowadays ago Teddy Roosevelt oh you mean
Franklin because we're young and dumb
and nobody reads a goddamn book anymore
[Music]
Woodrow Wilson was the president of
America
the United States of America Edith King
Wilson was the goddamn president's wife
so Woodrow Wilson he had 18 months left
in office he s in stroke his doctor was
like wardro Wilson has had a stroke a
big stroke like we can't move y'all
stroke so what you gon do I need it was
like well who I love is this man for who
he is and who he is is a guy who wants
to be President for some good reason so
if I don't just ignore that if I don't
just ignore that if I don't help him be
President
what a kind of wife am I the doctor is
like
you gonna run the country because this
guy's out for the count
so Edith was like no problem I got this
shut up sit down I am in charge now
can I get my cheesy bread I brought your
what cheesy bread that I brought can we
finish this part what it part the part
that we want to do
we're still doing it all right I don't
want the bread me more so eat at the
wall Center she told in America hey guys
excuse me my husband the president he's
very tired and he will be resting he's
very tired singing these stressed and
she even went to Congress and was like
hey no big deal I'm giving him
everything you're saying Congress I'm
giving him all the letters and the
things so what do you guys think of this
rule or Allah or thing that we're
working on and they'd be like everything
I should bring it to Woodrow who was
like half awake he's like all right well
Congress is like blah blah and he'd be
like um and she was like well I guess
I'll compromise I'm just gonna make the
decisions is gonna make the decision ISM
myself
so basically Edith Wilson was first
female president
she ran memos between Congress and him
Congress is like all right what what
what is going on so Congress picked this
one Republican senator Albert father
like Albert gonna see what's true
cognition that's Rosie Wilson's true
condition is so Albert fall shows up
he's like can we come in and see the
true condition she's not stupid she's
like yeah sure come on in
so ever fall comes in
[Music]
it was I got visa this is him
making decisions every day and then I
take the thank you honey and I take the
the papers from him that I don't
understand cuz I'm just some dumb broad
and eat it's just propped up Woodrow in
bed like waving like hey and they're
like oh okay cool
just like bye and then they leave that's
how dumb government is
[Music]
all this writes a letter to mix and
while on the plane
they've land he drops it off of the
front of the White House it was shocking
no celebrities gonna hang out with Nixon
so when he reached out there like all
those means to me this can't hurt
manners don't you want to see you they
all this has to say why not
the gap arranger yeah let me see what's
going on and Elvis comes in and Nixon
looks like I was crazy been really crazy
man hey you have your getup I have mine
okay
Nixon's like yeah I'm glad you came by
wanna meet you know good to see and
Elvis does the hard sell saying he needs
the Badger well I don't care man I care
about what's going on with these people
and I care about the hippies and
everything's being said right now but
it's terrifying people that are saying
things about you and people are saying
things about me and that's wrong I'm
happy to be here but I need this badge
that this is so big for me I need it
Nixon really takes it and kind of asses
aid said can we do this and the eight
comes back says I'm sorry it's done can
I get this badge sorry mr. Presley you
cannot you have no qualifications in our
mind to have this badge hmm sorry
brother I'm loving it
and Nixon decides to give him this badge
so Elvis goes back your photos taken but
then Elvis is a licensed and registered
federal narcotics agent
you